uh what kind of shows you been watching
lately you know what I'm really into
this show called Dragon Bungalow I've
never even heard of that yeah it's on
Prime you watch iron armor Wars It's on
Disney plus you ever seen a captain with
an exclamation point David Lynch's new
series have you seen Martin Schmidt as a
very bad boy no that's streaming on a TV
under a bridge there a troll guarding
hard to find have you seen guy onle is
there nothing we can talk about have we
become so atomized and trapped within
increasingly smaller and smaller bubbl I
don't know man the algorithms just
churning out content specifically for us
and we have no way to relate to others
anymore oh have you seen the new Mr
Beast video I did watch that yeah